[Music]
so
um john posted on instagram
uh i dared to do this that uh
that people should be nice to each other
and you did that on the day of the
inauguration people should be nice to
each other
and apparently it's not okay to say you
should be nice to each other
so just for everyone listening i it's
the most hate mail he's ever gotten
so i've really been messing with him so
the conservatives said you're a liberal
and all the liberals said well where
have you been to protect our
rights all along that's right so you you
just screwed up you screwed
everybody i used asking them to be nice
the u word oh i know don't use the u
word
and so i don't watch the news just as a
general principle because i care about
my mental and social and physical and
spiritual health so i stay away from
that
and i communicate with foreign
it evidently does so i'm walking through
the office
and i see the end of the inauguration i
stick my head in and say oh yeah that
was today
like a terrible citizen i get that and
then i see karl rove come out and say
i'm just gonna say it that was a good
speech and i thought
well america's over right and then i
thought yeah karl rove says it's a good
speech
biden has a good speech the second
coming of jesus is about on us
either it's freezing over or yeah hey
we're all coming together it's gonna
we're gonna come together and dave you
know me i
always think everyone's gonna come
together at the end
whoo boy so i'm leaving the office after
my show yesterday and i posted
hey it's time for everybody to come
together we're going to be unified we're
going to say i'm sorry we're going to
ask one more question like
i don't know what you mean by that can
you help me
you were asking people will be nice and
that's just illegal
just be kind i'm surprised that facebook
hasn't completely thrown you off because
i did that's kind of asking people to be
nice is hate speech john i have an
unread message from zuckerberg he
emailed me last night
i'll open it when i get the courage
could we just stop
we just stop people would rather have a
terrible day
than say hey man tell me what you mean
by that
people would rather have a bad marriage
the hilarious thing is is that you're so
politically naive
that you have no idea that you just
walked down the alley asking to get hit
by both sides well i told somebody
because it's like a gauntlet you walk
people are emailing i said you're so
funny i just walked through my
girlfriend's front yard and stepped in
dog poo and tracked it all over her
parents house without even realizing
that's what i did
i had no idea hey get this dave
the first person who wrote me said
something along the lines of
oh i see what's going on in china and
conspiracy and i
wrote back and i know no you didn't i
answered it hey i thought it was a
you've got to stop dave i wrote i wrote
hahaha awesome i thought they were
messing with me
here's the thing they were super dope
they're really mentally ill
they were not messing with me the
unabomber just sent you a message on
instagram
man listen listen hey the good news is
is that mental illness is everywhere and
so you got a big job
tell you what you got almost as big a
job as i do getting people out of debt
and jenny craig does
the three of us are going to be employed
are eternally employable
forever and if i'll just shut my mouth
the chest will just deposit themselves
be nice be nice let's be
let's be willing to listen to other
people's ideas
oh god you're a liberal
i do i didn't know i didn't i had to go
on instagram to find out john was a
liberal i had no idea
oh man oh man
i did can you imagine dave i think i
just think we need to stir in
anthony o'neal see if we can make it
even more messed up no when anthony
when anthony texts you and goes he just
wrote bro that's it
that's what i knew i'm probably in
trouble i don't know what i did
jeez louise well uh if you all don't
know john has been a
ramsey personality for a little under a
year now and so
he's gotten um a few baptisms by fire
and
learning that the trolls and the uh that
singular words misused in the wrong
timing
on social media will get you hate mail
by the bushel
well here's the thing dave we gotta bail
mine man i will oh
yeah we don't answer i answer all
letters that come today ramsay
they go to patty's desk we answer every
one of them except hate mail yeah and
um send them to me i'm going to respond
to them no no no
i use them for kindling there you go i
have to have something to light my fires
in the winter and there's a lot of
kindling at my house
so man yeah it's it's i'm not going to
stop
talking about this one thing okay
if somebody has hurt you in the past if
somebody
um disagrees with you
all going to ward accomplishes all find
if you if finding somebody new to hate
dave will not solve any of your problems
and if you want to have a conversation
great it doesn't mean kindness doesn't
mean you're going to agree
kindness doesn't mean we're not going to
fight hard kind means i'm going to be
respectful i'm going to listen to you
so i'm going to keep encouraging people
in your homes with your kids
in your workplace in your community
wherever
just listen first just listen and if you
don't understand
ask this next question i don't
understand what you mean by that
keep keep coming on that but fill me in
and man
you ought we often will find we are way
way closer together
on so many things man so many things you
see you're making the assumption there
that you're dealing with someone who's
not mentally i know
i know i just have such a high view of
people
you're so kind and sweet hey those
christians texted me last night
me listening to you ain't gonna keep you
from being stupid you're right so i'm
not gonna bother
email me i'll listen to you yeah john
he's he's sweet he's still
he's got still check it back check back
with him in one more year oh man
man after you've had a few more emails
from the unabomber and then we'll see
we're gonna blow up the building please
don't don't i want to tell my kids bye
yeah yeah well uh usually people that
are going to blow up the building don't
tell you they're going to so that's a
good news okay
shake man oh you're listening do not use
the word unity all right
don't don't don't say we want to be
unified don't say kindness
don't say nice just say don't say sorry
don't say say you're sorry
don't ever never be sorry never be sorry
i can't hey you know what those people
are gonna cut and paste this
and they're gonna say see and it's gonna
be me and dave going don't say sorry
don't say sorry
[Laughter]
you know what it ain't the first time
it's happened okay louise
there's so much video of me on youtube
that has been cut and pasted is it
awesome
it's just um yeah i've said a lot of
stuff i never said
hey james did that to me the other day
and it's fantastic man
yeah the guys in our booth they can put
together stuff
on us and they do it frequently just to
mess with us well the problem with james
is what i said i actually said
it's like i don't really have any other
context context is overrated i actually
say it it's the other thing yeah oh well
there we go
oh be kind america be kind be unified
slow down dave slow down too far down i
didn't say that i just said be kind
we got some crap we got to figure out